الناس ولكن أسعارنا ارتفعت ،
فقد ارتفعت تكاليفنا 45 في المتوسط
منذ أه منذ المذنب
[الموسيقى]
لذلك نحن قلقون حقًا من أن
تعرفهم مع
التأثير المركب الذي تعرفه عن
الرغبة في تغير المناخ أم
ونهاية الحرب في أوكرانيا التي
نراها مرة أخرى
تعلمون أن الصراع يأتي هجرة جماعية
تحدث
[موسيقى]
اليمن تستورد 90
من احتياجاتها
الغذائية ومع الأسعار
أخذوا حوالي 30 من البحر الأسود
الآن مع ارتفاع الأسعار.  هذا على نطاق واسع
آه أنت تعرف أن المزيد من الناس
يعانون من الجوع ، يوجد الآن 16 مليون
شخص في
اليمن لا يضعون الطعام على المائدة ، يكفي
wp يدعم 13 مليون شخص ، لكننا
ذهبنا إلى
نصف ما يحتاجه الشخص في اليوم
لأننا لا  لديهم الأموال الآن
[موسيقى]
يحتاجون إلى حوالي 5.2 مليون طن من
القمح ينتجون 2.3 مليون طن من القمح
فقط والباقي يجب
استيراده وبالطبع عندما تستورد بأسعار أعلى
برنامج الغذاء العالمي الذي تعرف
أنك تعلم أنه يخطط  الدعم  130 مليون
شخص هذا العام
تجاوزت ميزانيتنا الحد الأقصى بسبب
التكاليف المتزايدة